大家好，Config。大家好，我叫 Damian Carell。我非常荣幸能带领 Figma 这里才华横溢的品牌工作室团队。向他们致敬。我也非常开心、非常激动能来到这里，也很高兴介绍下一位讲者。Brent 是 Special Offer 的艺术总监。从定义一个夏天的那一抹绿色背后的过程，到支撑大型创意活动的系统思考，他都做过。
Brent 做过很多跨越专辑、杂志、现场媒体的设计工作，也推动过视觉文化。请大家欢迎他上台。谢谢。这里有一点点字幕像是从杂志印刷那一刻接过来的片段，不过总之，谢谢大家。
过去两天我在房间里想这件事的时候，已经把它说错很多次了。无论如何，这是 i-D 杂志。我很幸运，能和许多很棒的艺术家合作，做很多非常有趣的工作。我做设计师大概已经 24 年了吧。我暂时不告诉你们我的年龄，所以你们不用算。但真正让我在职业生涯后期开始做到现在这种规模的专辑视觉，是最近这些年。
我最早是做网站设计和开发的，研究怎么把小段 HTML 代码复制粘贴到一起。这大概就是我的背景。后来我有机会和 Miley Cyrus、Tame Impala 的《Deadbeat》这些项目合作。
最近还有 Rosalia 的《Lux》，那是一个很有意思的项目。下周 Madonna 的《Confessions on a Dance Floor Part Two》也要发布了。我真的，你们懂吗，接到 Madonna 的电话时，你会想：啊？你确定吗？但我想，大家可能更熟悉我的工作室和我，是因为我们帮助 Charli XCX 设计了一张叫《Brat》的专辑。
在聊《Brat》以及它背后的设计过程之前，我想先聊一点文化，聊我们如何体验文化，也聊粉丝文化。我真的相信，粉丝是建造互联网的人。通过论坛，通过各种沟通方式，粉丝让互联网成形。我也认为，粉丝是音乐人能够持续做自己所做之事的原因之一，是整个生态里最重要的一部分。
这是 1999 年的我。那时我 14 岁。现在你们可以开始算了。其实这个笑话没有成功。我当时没有朋友。有时候这个笑话也不太成立，因为大家可能会觉得有点尴尬。但事实是，我也并不真的想要朋友。我只是很沉浸在自己的世界里，和周围人不在同一个频率。
那种状态并不太顺。身边没有太多人能让我产生共鸣，也没有太多人能理解我。但这也没关系，完全没关系。我在新奥尔良外面的一座城市长大，大概离那里一小时车程。所以新奥尔良算是在伸手可及的范围里。去机场会去新奥尔良，买开学用品也会去新奥尔良。
但归根结底，我是在湖的另一边，离那里大概一小时。当你想到新奥尔良，你可能会想到 Bourbon Street、狂欢节，还有那种丰富而独特的文化，它确实是一个非常美妙的熔炉。但现实是，在密西西比的 Long Beach，氛围更像这样。
这张图其实很漂亮。我当时搜 tumbleweed，觉得这就是我想放上来的东西。但现实更像这张我一直很迷恋的 Martin Parr 照片。真正让我成长时撑下去的，是电视。我总是试图从电视里吸收尽可能多的东西。
尤其是 MTV。对小时候的我、一个青少年早期的我来说，MTV 是一种方式，让我能够接触、参与并接收关于文化、流行文化、时尚、身份认同，当然还有音乐的信息。
它让我能暂时离开自己所在的地方，理解更大世界里正在发生什么。我真的很迷 MTV。你几乎任何时候都能看到我在看它，白天看，晚上看，不睡觉，就是 MTV、MTV、MTV。可能到了父母应该担心的程度，但还好他们没有太担心。
我在 MTV 上最喜欢、最沉迷的节目叫《The Real World》。这个节目讲的是七个 18 到 24 岁的年轻人被放到一栋房子里生活。它是最早的连续剧式真人秀，用一种纪录片方式拍摄。整个季里，你会看到他们之间的对话、争吵，以及各种互动。
而我在《The Real World》的每一季里，都能在每一位成员身上看到自己，能和这些人产生连接。所以他们变成了我的朋友。当然，是拟社会关系里的朋友，他们并不知道我的存在。但我非常沉迷。这里是片头。
这是真实故事。七个陌生人被选中住进一栋房子，他们的生活因此改变。看看当人们不再只是保持礼貌，而开始真实起来时，会发生什么。《The Real World: San Francisco》。让我们为《The Real World》鼓掌。
在我还是青少年的时候，《The Real World》大概已经有八季。从纽约到洛杉矶，到旧金山、伦敦、迈阿密、波士顿，到很多地方。每一季都是七个新人，而且总是七种不同类型的人，不会和之前季里的人完全一样。所以对我来说，它是一种理解不同人、认识不同视角的方式。
九年级的时候，我们发现它要在新奥尔良拍摄。我真的彻底疯了。我想，什么？你说什么？于是我每天都让我妈妈开车带我去新奥尔良。
我会站在那栋房子前面，感受那里的能量。我会在外面待好几个小时。顺便一提，那时我很迷男士饰品。比如你想要一条麻绳项链吗？我来给你做一条麻绳项链。
于是我坐在那栋房子外面，给节目成员做麻绳项链。现在想起来，这真的是最书呆子、最尴尬的事情之一。你们可以看到我妹妹在旁边像是在想：我们到底在干什么？
我会把自己的地址绑在这些项链上，然后把它们扔到门廊上。几个星期过去了，基本什么都没有发生。后来他们停拍，完成了这一季，然后去剪辑，把它做成最后播出的样子。
我一直有点难过，因为我没有真正经历那个打破第四面墙的瞬间，而那正是我想要的。后来有一天，我在家，可能又在看电视。我记得妈妈、外婆、妹妹都在。妈妈拿着一封她发现的信走进来，那是一位节目成员寄给我的信。
几年前，疫情期间，我妈妈把很多录像带数字化了。里面有一段短片，记录了我收到那封信的整个过程。所以我现在要放给你们看。里面我尖叫了很多。我们直接看吧。
这里是当时的家庭录像片段。大家在让我拿刀打开信封，提醒我不要弄坏信封。旁边还有人说，Brent 看到里面是什么以后一定会疯掉。那一刻所有人都在催我把信打开。
这个片段很混乱，也很真实。它记录了一个少年收到来自电视那一端的回应时，完全无法控制自己的激动。
这真的太疯狂了。2020 年左右，我妈妈把这些录像带数字化。我对这个时刻记得非常清楚，它是我人生里非常关键的时刻。多年后能重新看到它、得到它、展示它，看到那个我在脑海里清楚保存了将近三十年的瞬间，真的让我震惊。
通过那封信，我和那位演员成了笔友。我们会交换混音 CD，她会给我推荐可能喜欢的艺术家，也会和我聊时尚。但其中最重要的一件事，是你们刚才可能听到了，那封信最后提到她正在上线自己的网站，叫 princesselissa.com。
那是在社交媒体、社交网络之前。那只是她在世界上的一个小角落，她学会了把 HTML 片段复制粘贴在一起，做出一个博客，让人们能跟随她，看看她在《The Real World》之后的生活。
我每天都会看那个网站。我会读它，反复读，尽可能从里面吸收一切。我能感觉到节目播出后，她正在塑造一种生活方式。我甚至把自己的幽默感部分地照着她来塑造。我觉得我们很相似，也感觉她知道我们之间有这种相似。
那封信像是她从电视那一边伸出手，抓住我，说：嘿，我们会确保你走到你该去的地方。后来她搬到洛杉矶，在那里建立社区，也建立自己的生活。
等我一到 18 岁，我也搬去了洛杉矶，因为我是个疯子。顺便说一句，到那时我们已经不再通信了，这是四年后的事。当然，这只是对当时发生事情的过度简化。通过 princessmelissa.com，还有我后来自己做网站、开博客的经历，我开始遇到其他喜欢同样乐队的人。
我开始在粉丝留言板里找到社区。很多人都住在洛杉矶。所以我知道，只要我到了那里，就会有一群人和一个社区，在那里等着我，让我可以交朋友，每天见到他们，真正生活在其中。
所以 18 岁时我搬去了洛杉矶。其实我不认识什么人。严格来说，我没有搬到洛杉矶，我搬到了 West Covina，那并不是洛杉矶，你们可能知道。但它在洛杉矶县，所以我当时还想，为什么房租这么便宜？后来你就懂了。接下来的 15 年，我一直住在洛杉矶。
我在那里交朋友，和那些对我关心的东西同样感兴趣的人一起工作。他们在做一些我想帮忙的事，而我用设计作为帮助别人做事的方式。如果朋友要开一个服装品牌，我知道自己可以用设计做一个 logo，再把它导出到需要的东西上，比如印在 T 恤上。
如果朋友在乐队里，需要巡演海报，我就用一种很拼凑的方式把它做出来，然后说：我觉得它可以长这样。但我其实从来没有真正学过，也从来不太知道自己在做什么。我只是对和人在一起、帮助他们、把他们想做的事情推进下去很感兴趣。
那是一种真正的协作。所以接下来的 15 年，我基本上就是在混、在和朋友待在一起。这是我和很多朋友一起玩的照片。我在这里。这里还有一个我曾经短暂拥有过的发型，挺悲伤的。有一阵子，我甚至和朋友组过乐队。
那个乐队并不好，我也不擅长，但我每天都戴这顶水手帽，我以为那就是所谓氛围。总之，我想说的是，对我来说，设计其实是后来才出现的东西。它是我用来帮助、沟通和协作的工具，用来和那些已经在创造东西的人一起工作。
我就这样在洛杉矶生活了很久，一直和大家待在一起，做那些事。快进 15 年，中间当然发生了很多很多事情。到了 2023 年，我收到一位同事或者朋友 Imagene 的消息，她是 Charli XCX 的创意总监。
我知道 Charli，也知道她音乐的大致感觉，但我不会说自己是特别大的粉丝。我知道那些热门歌，也觉得她正在做的事情很酷、很有意思。我也会想，太好了，有人想让我给他们做专辑视觉。首先，为什么是我？我可是做网站设计的，这才是我的日常工作。
他们大概说，我们想要一张以文字排版为核心的专辑。我们想要它感觉像设计，想要它不像 2024 年整个视觉环境里其他东西那样。于是我把他们讲的很多内容，把他们为《Brat》定义出的性格结构，那些《Brat》是什么、不是什么，都带进 Figma，开始试着弄清楚它。
接下来我会共享屏幕，给大家看一些东西。每当我刚接到一个项目，我第一件事就是去翻自己一直在收集的图片库。我收集了很多图片，可能是在 Instagram 上看到的，也可能是在网上看到的，或者是在街上看到的。
我会拍很多招牌，拍很多各种各样的东西，像是在数字层面囤积所有我喜欢、我觉得酷、我白天可能偶然看到的东西。所以每次开始一个项目时，我会把这个项目放在脑子里，想着它的主要部分可能是什么样、它的性格是什么。
然后我会去翻我的图片库。比如这是今年的图库。我会在脑子里一张一张问：这是它吗？不是。这是它吗？不是。不是，不是，不是。是。不是，不是。就这样看两千张图，或者一年里我收集的所有图。
我特别提到这一点，是因为我认为作为设计师，我们真正的工作不在最终设计本身，而在于收集想法和设计，在于能被启发、能看到其他东西，把它们带进自己的脑子里。这才是工作。
工作不是花时间坐在电脑前做那个东西，努力把它做对。工作是在体验，在尽可能吸收一切，在疯狂消费媒体和内容。于是我这样做了，也为《Brat》找到了一些我知道是对的东西。Charli 一直非常明确，她知道她想让封面写着 brat，也知道她想让它是绿色。
在这样一个非常具体的方向下，我开始搭建一些东西，帮助理解专辑封面最终会处在怎样的世界里。我知道它会很简单、很排版化，但还有很多东西需要从零开始搭起来，才能理解黑胶包装最终要如何以不同方式运作。
我的鼠标跑偏了。顺便说一句，如果你是设计师但不用鼠标，你真的应该开始用鼠标。这是我最大的烦恼之一。你不能用触控板，真的不行。效率上必须用鼠标。所以我开始翻自己的素材库，把里面所有相关的东西拉出来。颜色，任何绿色的东西，我都拉进来。
这是我们以前一个节日派对，上面还有我的狗。这是我某年去韩国时拿到的一张海关表格。我当时想，这是我这辈子见过最美的东西，我该拿它怎么办？于是拍了照片。还有我狗狗常去的宠物店。我也开始思考其他专辑视觉，或者其他只用文字、只用排版的东西。
我在想，它们如何承载重量，如何变得标志性，或者如何具有描述性。我喜欢 Martine Rose 做的这条绿色裤子。这是我几年前为 Whitney Houston 做的一个水瓶设计。所以你可以看到，我把任何感觉可能属于《Brat》世界的东西都拉了进来。
这里有很多东西。这个是我最喜欢的，不知道它为什么最终进入了选择范围，但它就是在那儿。以某种渗透性的方式，它成了《Brat》视觉的一部分。这里还有很多系统化排版、字体、材质感的东西。任何我感觉可能属于《Brat》宇宙的东西，不管它是否和我的设计师职责直接相关，我都放进来。
然后我们开始一起看，决定它应该长什么样。字体是什么，颜色是什么，大小写是什么，字距是什么，字偶距是什么，字号是什么，构图是什么，它应该给人什么感觉。看到它时，什么最真实、最响亮。
老实说，作为设计师，我知道很多人认为你必须非常编辑化地展示自己的设计工作，只展示那些你真正希望被选中的东西。你可以给一个方向，说：好，这是三个选项。但我一直不是这种人。
我一直更倾向于说，让我们看看我在这一轮里做过的所有东西。很大一个原因是，通过展示所有这些东西，包括很多我自己不喜欢的东西，我才能说：正是经过这些，我得出了这一轮里我真正喜欢的东西。
所以我常说，设计是一种信任关系。当你和其他人、和客户一起工作时，如果没有一种盲目的相互信任，这件事就行不通。信任是必要的。而获得这种信任的唯一方式，是建立关系，是能够展示你的工作，展示你的参考。
你要解释自己理解正在发生什么，解释你对这件事的看法，并带来一些真正有价值、真正感觉正确的东西。所以显然，我看了很多绿色的东西。我也看了很多 Radiohead 的包装，那些我非常着迷。还有这个，我觉得是一个很酷的泡沫塑料质感的东西。这是 Charli 的《Von Dutch》视频。
我觉得那是非常棒的东西。我一直很迷机场里的数字视觉。所以我开始不断翻找、不断拉这些东西进来。下一轮我们有了摄影。现在我们有了专辑拍摄，也开始知道围绕它的世界是什么样。从语气、视觉、造型的角度，我们开始理解它的氛围。
我们也继续收紧上一轮里仍然觉得最好的东西。这里面仍然有很多糟糕的东西。我觉得这也是我们常常会被困住的一点：如果一个东西不好，它就必须消失，我不能把它留在身边，我们必须离它远一点。
而且每一轮都必须比上一轮更好、更好、更好。我不认为是这样。我认为这是一个误解：设计一、设计二、设计三，好像每一轮都应该越来越好，越来越接近最终答案。有时候你只是在探索更多，学习更多。
你是在定义它不应该是什么，从而理解这件事的边界。经过这些图像探索之后，Charli 他们说：我们喜欢，继续吧。但我们确实需要做专辑封面。我说，好，那就做吧。
于是我们进入颜色和字体，试图理解重量、构图的理由。为什么某些更深，某些更浅？我们想要的语气是什么？它要有多特别？以及那件永无止境的事：选择字体。
我也想说，自从《Brat》之后，我会告诉所有来 Special Offer 工作的设计师：你不需要找到那个正确字体。你可以坚持用你喜欢、并且知道如何控制的那五个字体。很多人会觉得，只要找到正确字体，一切就会对，这个字体会让整件事成立。但这不是真的。
你需要找到一种凝胶一样的东西，需要知道自己在和什么一起工作，知道自己最喜欢哪些，哪些最能被你控制，哪些能承载最多工作。最终经过这些之后，Charli 做了选择。顺便说一句，这已经是高度缩略版了。
我还要说，这是我第一次真正使用 auto layout，因为我有时候点到 auto layout，会立刻想，不不不，我不知道该怎么办。但我知道 Special Offer 的每个人都喜欢 auto layout。对我来说，它不是我的重点。我们不必展开。我的意思是，你可以用自己想用的方式使用 Figma。
经过所有这些，我们得到了一个选择。Charli 选了这个，非常明确，也很顺利。但接下来的问题是，怎么把它做成印刷品？怎么把它印到黑胶上？我当时想，糟了，我是在 Figma 里做的，怎么才能把它印出来？我又不想只是重新做一遍。
于是我开始从一个小截图出发，尝试各种方式，把它推向更接近最终印刷的状态。这里中间有一段演示过程，主要是在不断导出、调整、再导出，寻找它从屏幕走向实体包装的方式。
我当时想，好，这越来越接近了。然后我导出，做到了一万两千像素。现在可以关掉屏幕共享，让我回到我朴素的幻灯片。很明显，我们当时完全不知道《Brat》会发生什么，会变成什么。
我只是很高兴能把 Charli 带到一个她非常满意的地方，让她觉得这张封面以正确的方式代表了她的专辑。当然，《Brat》发布之后，音乐接管了一切，真正渗透进文化。她也借由这张专辑，向人们展示了自己非常有趣、非常不羁的一面。
也是在那之后，我才意识到，通过《Brat》的反复使用，通过这套视觉的反复使用，《Brat》其实变成了一个界面本身。很多人开始重新使用它。在纽约，MTA 也做了一个。它像 G 线，但今天又不是 G 线，是 M 线。总之，我只想要一个能正常运行的地铁系统。
我记得当时有点分不清，这到底只是我的算法在推给我，还是我爸妈也在不停发东西给我，说你看，Ritz 饼干做了 Brat Ritz。然后我想，好，我知道了。NATO 也做了一个写着 peace 的版本。我当时想，姐妹，世界上真的有战争。但谢谢你发截图。
通过这一切，我意识到，真正完成设计过程最后一部分的，是粉丝，是他们对这套视觉的接收。我们在那之前做的一切，其实都只是希望它能和那件事完美契合。
所以我认为，观众对设计的回应，才是流程里的最后一步。一个人如何回应某个东西，它让他们产生什么感觉，他们如何把它带进自己的生活，或者他们为什么不想让它进入自己的生活，这些本身都是设计过程的一部分。
它不是之后发生的，不是后期结果。我认为观众就是媒介。我们真正想做的，是让人们对我们所爱的东西产生非常身体化、非常直觉的反应。就像当年的我坐在电视机前看《The Real World》，只是想成为某件事的一部分，想理解周围文化里正在发生什么。
即使我只是坐在密西西比 Long Beach 的卧室里，我也需要找到其他人，找到可以一起工作、一起理解、一起协作的人。所以我总是说，没有所谓完成状态。
只要你愿意，每一件设计都会永远活下去。即使你认为某个东西已经完成了，已经发布了，已经印刷了，已经做完了，两年、三年、四年后，当你甚至已经不再想它时，它仍然是一个进行中的作品。你仍然可以回到它那里，它仍然会再次改变。没有终点。
通过这个过程，我学到的很大一部分是：我本来可以永远迭代下去。我可以永远调整字体、选颜色、缩放、排版，可以一直做下去。真正把我从那种隧道视野里拉出来的，是像 Charli 这样的人说：我们完成了，就是这个。
作为设计师，我的工作是不断继续，不断推动、推动、再推动，尽可能把所有东西都放出来，让它们全部出现。
我非常感谢能有这样的合作者一起做到这一点。我认为这也是我们都必须寻找的东西。它是真正关于社区、关于生活、关于这些事情的证明。非常感谢大家，谢谢你们邀请我。